vous avez été
votre film non c'est sympa il attend
quoi pas content c'est pas
définitivement d'ici mais c'est pas un
thème de filles
il ya des critères précis tu vois envers
l'association de rugby
rossé le pdc le bureau des élèves suffit
de rentrer dans cinq là pour baiser
et toutes ces filles a forcément bien
non mais c'est pas une question bien je
voulais sur un marché mais quelle marche
tu parles du marché sexuelle
en gros si c'est bien une sitcom ça une
soirée de l'école tu la fais forte avec
jafar moins théoriquement il peut
coucher avec n'importe quelle fille
potable sur le campus
cette histoire c'est une occasion de me
faire peur avec tout le monde ici
j'espère a raison
et achète enfin recrute je veux dire un
truc le premier truc c'est que tu es
belle
et moi je prends c'est pas une question
de savoir si tu es capable ou non de
cuxa été tués dans tout le monde vous
amuser c'est donnant donnant tu vas voir
un boycottage jamais vue et aurait
jamais dû voir crème de la crème
moi comme genre de fille mais je sais
par où comme quoi tout nature
oh
défi de l'école nous ont balancé réponse
n'est pas ça qu'on avait prévu au départ
il se passe quoi sinon sorte sur
internet c'est un peu chaud pour vous
franchement
si j'avais su qu'elle était payée je
leur aurais fait des trucs bien plus
grave